When dealing with science, it is normal to
we categorize large groups of objects like
things that are unimaginably small.
When people talk about things with atom,
molecular,
protein or cell size,
often group them together
and they say that's really a lot,
very small things.
What I want to do in this video
is to explain that even
all the things I mentioned are very small,
there is a huge difference
in their dimensions.
I hope that this way you can appreciate
how complicated it may be like a cage.
How can all these organelles exist?
How it can be a living organism or
part of a living organism?
Here on this scale
I have painted
water molecule.
We have oxygen
in purple
and two hydrogen atoms,
related to oxygen.
This will be rough around
0.275 nanometers.
And just to recall,
one nanometer is one billionth
from the meter.
To understand how little this is -
-
It is
one billion
one billionth of a meter.
That's one nanometer.
And if you're trying to be
give it up,
it will be one millionth
of the millimeter.
I will write it,
one millionth
by one millimeter.
I like this definition,
because it's a millimeter
the smallest unit of measurement,
which I can visualize really well.
But one millionth of a millimeter
is far above my options
for visualization.
This will be the diameter or
the width of the water molecule.
Now, let's go to a larger size.
We've talked a lot about the proteins
and this is our start friend here
-
hemoglobin.
Now you will begin to understand the scale better,
the hemoglobin width will be
about five nanometers.
Or five billionth of a meter.
This may seem very little,
so it might be good to categorize
these objects are extremely small.
But it is good to be able to appreciate that
hemoglobin is much larger than the water molecule.
If the water molecule was placed on this scale -
I drew this little thing in advance,
this is my attempt to draw
molecule of water
in the hemoglobin scale.
Even when we move from
water molecule to protein,
we have a dramatic increase in size
and the complexity of the molecules.
We have talked a lot about the structure of proteins,
about how they can all have these
interesting forms and perform a lot
surprising and complex features
in biological systems.
But let's go one more step up.
The next step
are the vurs.
What I have tried to draw here,
is a well-known virus.
This is HIV.
It is one of the major viruses,
its diameter is about
120 nanometers.
If we draw
this hemoglobin,
the hemoglobin protein on the scale in which
I've painted this virus,
this here
will be hemoglobin.
And the water molecule can not be seen
at this scale.
-
However, the virus is very, very small.
That's 120 billion
by one meter.
That's still it
unimaginably small size.
Let's climb one more
step up.
This ominous picture
here
is the T cell.
This is a drawing,
if you want to see
the entire T cell,
she is here.
This is a T cell.
And on this ominous picture,
blue
is the T cell,
and the yellow shows
HIV virus coming out of the T cell
and uses it for their needs.
That's why it's ominous.
The virus uses the organs of the cell,
to reproduce.
You can see this picture right now
how small is the HIV virus
compared to the T cell.
Each of these little things -
each of these little things
is the HIV virus, as we have already seen
is much bigger
of the hemoglobin protein.
So hemoglobin
will not be visible
on this scale, against the T-cell background
or will be the most
one pixel.
Scale similar to T-cell
have red blood cells.
Here is a comparison of both
next to each other.
This photo is used
electronic microscope.
You see the red blood cell here,
as well as the T-cell.
Both have similarities
dimensions.
Or at least their dimensions are on the same scale.
The red blood cell is
about six to eight micrometers
wide.
These are six to eight million
from the meter.
Assuming the average size
for seven micrometers,
these are
seven million
seven
millionth
from the meter.
Here we are talking about
millionth of a millimeter.
Now we are talking about seven million
from the meter.
And to understand the dimensions,
we have already compared
HIV virus with this cell.
We see the virus
goes out of the cage.
Each of these red blood cells
will contain close
280 million hemoglobin molecules.
-
Will have
280 million of these molecules.
280 million,
these are millions
millions of molecules of hemoglobin
in each cell.
I hope this starts to
tells you that
even categorizing
cells like these unthinkable little things,
they are actually much larger,
giant are compared to other objects
even when compared to large proteins.
Especially compared to
molecules and atoms.
That's why the cells are so interesting.
They are very complicated
and complex.
Now we'll explain how much
small are the cells,
even though we described it a while ago
red blood cells and T-cells
as it targets the worlds in its own right.
They are very complicated.
If I paint the width
of human hair
on this screen,
compared to size
of these red blood cells,
he will whole screen the video.
If I draw a human hair,
roughly speaking, it will start from here and it will get here.
There is a lot of variety
in the width of the human hair.
But the width of a human hair
will look like this.
If you look at the scale
on this photo here,
if you look at these scales,
the hair will be much, much larger.
We can think of the width of
human hair as for -
Cut your hair one.
Look at him.
Put it on a piece of paper,
it's hard to even notice his breadth.
And we say that the width of the hair,
compared to these red blood cells,
will take the width of
the entire screen of the video.
And as we have already said, red blood cells
and T-cells
are worlds in their own right when we compare them
with the scale of viruses and molecules.